so welcome welcome I am el dia vache and
I will speaker but the work we have
perform during the last few years with
my book about the kinetic modulation of
the visual perception in rodents so the
work is performed at the School of
Optometry at university of montreal and
it's the first day of spring today so I
would like to share with you the nice
picture street of material so i would
like to sign the organizer for giving me
the opportunity to present the work over
his wide audience and i would like to
preside that i have no conflict of
interest or no financial relationship
with the presentation also this talk
will be a review of the published work
that we have performed there is other
were coming during the next year or so
you are invited to to look at it and
there is also a lot of different groups
working on the similar subject with the
same subject so they're also very they
are also doing it very exciting research
so I will ask you to not record film or
we could use the torque and don't put it
on YouTube business thank you so why
looking at the visual perception you
know that million of personal
experiences visual deficits during aging
so these the visual deficits can write
great up to fifteen percent of the
population over 75 years old and mom so
it is a visual deficit are due to values
a cloud or neurological disease like
stroke and making a disease idts and not
form of the visual path so it will be it
could take an incredible amount of time
to try to find a cure or
or for all of these codons of the visual
deficits so in my laboratory we want to
vm of a research work is to improve the
visual capacity by enhancing the
cortical function and the residual
vision so the modulation of visual
perception then what is it exactly so it
allows the acquisition of new visual
capacity a sign of your perception or
acquisition of new visual visual
capacity I mean for example you will
look at electron microscopy picture and
at the beginning we see nothing so you
will learn to discriminate different no
no elements within teaser it's a
structure a picture so the improvement
of the visual capacity is also due to
visual learning and as all learning you
know the more you practice the visual
the visual exposure does the more you
are exposed to the stimulus the more you
will learn and understand distinguish is
like practicing a music instrument you
will you will get the final year you
will get finer skills so you need some
training so the modulation of the visual
perception need training to improve your
visual skilled so then at the level of
the brain it the visual perception
enhancement result of change of the
neuronal activity and specifically in
the visual cortex and the primary visual
cortex so let me remind you how the
visual system is working so
when you get an image the image will be
captured by the retina and will be sent
to the visual cortex of v1 through the
dose orogenic little appendages and in
v1 the visa neurons responding to a
specific attributes of the image of the
same for example the sorry the neurons
will response to the location of the
image within the visual appeal for for
example some neurons will respond to
image esteem booster located in the
upper right corner or the bottom left
corner so not all the neurons respond to
the same nasty nurse also they will
respond to different contrast intensity
some neurons will respond to I contrast
images other neurons will respond to
global low contrast intensity
orientation is also natural beauty that
neurons will respond to so some neurons
will respond to vertical stimulus other
will respond to always on that stimulus
the direction also if the stimulus is
moving the different visual neurons we
respond to view different movies DVD so
the spatial frequency is also an
attribute of image for which the new own
develop selectivity so v1 it's important
to understand that we the one is the
first integration later and some
information with your information will
then filter analyze and process within
ir cortical areas and through a dorsal
pathway which is the web pathway or a
ventral pathway which is the word
pathway the I mean the increase pathway
the people the neurons will analyze the
characteristic of the object or the
identification of the object so to get a
visual perception improvement you have
to change the activity of the neuron
within v1 to prioritize certain type of
information and also you have to get
long-term changes because training and
you want to get a stable perception so
you have to get long-term change in the
visual acuity so then what will modulate
the activity of the v1 new ones the
first example for example it's the
attention the top down and specially the
total attention from the Iowa cognitive
areas like the prefrontal cortex the
neurons within the prefrontal cortex
which modulate the activity of the
neurons in v1 so they can enhance the
equity of the attendees degree the
neurons that respond to attend gets to
me and I will decrease the activity of
neurons that do not respond to Adams TV
so the for example if you want to focus
on the Mona Lisa faces on please image
and not so no na da da Vinci the
prefrontal cortex will modulate the
neural responding to his face and it
will also depress the neurons that did
not respond to this face so there is
another way to modulate the cortical
activity of t1 neurons it's the
neuromodulatory system so the
neuromodulatory system they do not carry
a specific function like a threatening
visual information or digital
information and so on they will modulate
the activity of the specific system
involving specific function so the
kinetic stay
is one of the system and another one we
are really interested in so i will tell
you why very soon the cholinergic system
so is very important in terms of
modulating the visual cortex activity
because it is involved in cognitive
functions such as attention lon memory
and working memory so it's you know
everybody a few probably knows somebody
who got the Alzheimer disease which is a
deficit of the kinetics functioning
within the brain so the the kinematic
system is involved in attentional
processes so for more reading about this
subject you may want to read the reviews
from martin's out there for example to
know better about the war of the
Kentucky the role of the kinetic system
on the condition so then why does a
satirical in specifically to v1 neurons
if you administer ate the acetylcholine
know another an analog in the capital in
v1 you can modulate the activity of the
new ones either by enhancing activity or
by reducing the activity of the neurons
depending on the later depending on the
nature of the room neurons so the action
of philosophically is very complex but
you can see also different video
including the one on alexander deal
which is a really written and very
complete so as a normal modulatory
system the cholinergic system act by
enhancing the activity amount of a
nozzle system and specifically the
sensory system are boosted by the
cholinergic system so there is the
pyonium work
of the madman Michael kill Gabe and
Michael knowledge we show that by
coupling the stimulation of an auditor
specifically during stimulus to killeen
Ezekiel stimulation there were able to
Lucien to increase the number of cells
responding to the Train stimulus and so
to change the cortical representation
lapse of the stimulus in the cortex so
it's a really interesting and it shows
long-term changes of the auditory
perception so to finalize the
introduction about the chronometric
system you can see here schematics about
the microcircuitry within the v1 the
visual cortex so here one so we are
mostly interesting by two layers the
linear 23 and the lady are poor because
the layer for we see the terrible
cortical appearance so the information
that comes from the retina and the layer
23 and we'll send the information to
upper critical areas so you can see I
increase the layer different network of
cells the blue tonight algae cells blue
and the gabaergic cells in red the
gabaergic cells are inhibitory
interneurons so in green you can see
here the coding magic fibers which
innervates the world the cortical layers
of the v1 so as a tickle in is then
release in the visual cortex as an it
act as a diffuse transmission that's
mean it is released from the fibers to
the different cells and neurons it
diffuses filly in the nerve
here and it doesn't need synaptic
contact to do an action so there is
something that you contact that usually
it works as a diffuse transmission so as
a typical in will go and dine on
different receptor so the neutronic
receptor m1 which is excitatory and one
and three and the inhibitory mechanic
receptor m2n flow and teaser visitor are
seven transmembrane domain receptors
also they combine on an echogenic
receptor which are mostly located on the
thalamocortical fibers and in neurons of
the later one so when the acetylcholine
binds these receptor so there is as I
told you a very complex action either by
facilitating the neurons response or
decreasing the neuron responds are doing
nothing on the neuron neural response
but finally the acetylcholine increase
the thalamocortical input the strength
of the inputs and also it plays on the
relationship between the cortical cells
you know the or horizontal relationships
connectivity of the cells by depressing
or increasing the kiss connectivity and
also it will play on the input output
sorry of the Lydia 23 and so the main
action will result in enhancing some
stimulation and reducing some other
stimulation so changing the signal to
know nose noise ratio and the processing
of particular interest to higher
cortical areas
so then now you know a lot about the
kinetic system and the many ipod is is
that we think that it will contribute to
visual learning in the v1 so we have
very small hypotheses that we wanted to
test in the work that i will present you
today so the first of all is to know
whether the kinetic modulation of v1
induces the ipod is it is that it will
induce long-lasting senses because you
will never have improvement of the
perception without long lasting changes
of the neuronal property the second one
is that it will work with mechanic and
nicotinic receptor and the last one and
the most important is that the
neurobiological change that you can see
within the v1 will be correlated to
behavioral change that mean an
improvement of the visual perception so
to investigate these different
hypotheses and we I will present a
couple of studies and we will use a
different methodological approaches
immunocytochemistry because we want to
analyze the relationship between the
different neurons and fibers the animal
your chemical nature of the renewals we
use also behavior because we want to
measure of your equity we want to injure
visual perception and discrimination of
the the capacity of discrimination of
the animals and also we use actual
physiology very basic electrophysiology
to measure the change of the level of
the activity of the neurons so I will
speak about three studies that we have
performed and
and see studies are to see what is a the
effect of the deficit of the creamy
chicken neurons in v1 so does people who
don't have in kinetic innovation won't
see anything that does the vision is
impaired or not and the second one is to
see whether the when you pair the
stimulation sensory visual stimulation
to cleaners estimation do you have
long-term effect within the brain and
also if you do repetitive training so as
if you were practicing a visual exposure
to a particular visual stimulus do you
have do you change the visual perception
so two before have you wanted to do some
experiments to be sure about to
characterize the innovation cutting edge
recognization in v1 so the kinetic
innovation of the war nautical mantle
arises from the basal forebrain so the
basal forebrain is a structure at the
base of the brain which which carries
different neurons nucleus of neurons for
example the necklace magnocellular knees
or no clothes Duggan's of maynards the
substantial in a minute I'll septum
diagonal band of broca and so these
different nucleus are organized
topographically so to know which kind of
which population of neurons sent their
projections and fibers to the visual
cortex we did perform meet regarding
studies in which we inject the tracer
with
v1 as you can see everyone is in the
occipital lobe and we visualized the new
ones which were labelled so either year
a little with gloom or yellow necklace
that's mean that the the red rocket
racer has been taken up by the
projection between v1 and then sent back
to the nucleus in the bit of forebrain
you can see that the neurons are
labouring red which is a marker for the
green algae cells the curiosity
transference so on this different
governor section of the rat's brain we
wanted to so we located the position of
the neurons within the basal forebrain
and it is represented as the little also
a little black dots here and you can see
that the t-cells are mainly located
within the horizontal elem of the
diagonal band of broca and also little
bit on the substantial matta so the
neurons that project will be one are
located in threes nucleus hdb and when
we will have to manipulate the kinetic
input to be one we will target tease
necklace either to stimulate it or to
decrease the activity so the cholinergic
innovation of the cortex is also very
dance you can see it on this confer call
microscopy section and photographs the
kinetic fibrils are in green you can see
also a nice terminals that the internal
Cody Cody magic inter neurons in the
cortex are no more than ten percent of
the different
the different kinda Technovation sorry
so the cholinergic innovation is very
dance is located within every layer of
the coptic cairo v1 and it is reaching
the red cells here which are greater
metallic cells label for the transporter
of little nuts which is a specific for
the new ones also you can see here the
blue cells which are label receivers
Cephas is a transcription transcription
factor that is expressed in the cells
that is going to neuronal activity and
it will transcribe genes involved in
ensign a progenies so you can see here
that the rhythm actor cheek cells if you
look at the arrows here the
glutamatergic cells that are activated
during a visual activation visual
stimulation will are innervated by
kinetic system fibers so the fibers are
able to modulate the activity of t-cells
which respond to visual activation so
that's fine we have green ajik fibers
innovating with a metallic cells and so
on but what about the release of the
city couldn't east is the release of
acetylcholine constant or is it Express
easy to physic induced by different
kingdom so to answer this question we
wanted to see whether ascetical in words
released during a visual stimulation so
for that we did the insert microbial in
this probe within the visual cortex and
you can see beyond the present value at
section the location of the probes and
the probes is
the fuse with extracellular fluids and
the extracellular friends will be
collected and as if you couldn't will be
L say by IH pxe so during the visual
stimulation as you can see here showed
by these arrows there is a increase in
the level of the acetylcholine release
which drop down very fast lead to the
baseline so the first thing is that the
release of acetylcholine induced by
visual stimulation is physics so it is
triggered by visual estimation and it
would've stopped very rapidly the second
things to notice is that when you
implant a probe in the prefrontal cortex
so we need a double implantation there
was no increase of diversity cleaner it
is in this cortex so that's mean that
release of a city clean is very specific
of the modality and involved and it's
not released over the world catechol
mental generalize or which induce the
neuronal activity as in the paradoxical
sleep a story so it's a really selective
of the visual neurons of the neurons
which are activated so then knowing is
that we wanted to do not know first what
does the religion of the cells
projecting to the v1 on the visual
discrimination performance and also on
the activity of the neurons in v1 so we
did the region after the fibers as i
will show you new so I
in the upper panel in a and B sorry we
it represent a micro photograph of the
cholinergic fiber in a it's the control
animal more and indie it's the region
animal so we did inject toxin the v1 igg
supporting which is a specific for the
cholinergic fibers and the cholinergic
neurons from the basal forebrain so as
you can see in be the the lesion of the
file cholinergic innervation of the v1
is very ninety percent impairment so
when will you do the control when you do
a visual stimulation on on the animal
and you want to see the activity of the
neurons within v1 you can see in see
that there is an increased number of
neurons expressing the Cephas so maybe
you don't see it very well but there is
a lot of different black dots and these
black dots are not so dust in the tissue
its cells visual cells that are excited
by the visual stimulation and express
suppose and when you do igg supper in
the lesion so there is no more kinetic
fibers in you are so indie you can see
that there is no more expression of
Cephas in the v1 also when you block the
mechanic transmission by giving
scopolamine to the animals you blog also
to the expression of Cephas so thats
mean the cholinergic innovation is very
important for the expression of sick
first in v1 so I have to set a
that the expression of Cephas is not
only the activity of those cells because
i don't think that blazing the chromatic
fibers will stop every activity in v1
but it can be an index or so of the
synapses unity these after cells of the
involvement of the cells in a long term
processing as we will see after so then
if the the activity of the neuron is
changed by the lesion of the nomes does
the visual a quickie of the anomalies
change that it's don't see well or as an
added official deficit so as you know we
are using rats and the rats are not very
good for reading different letters on a
chart and saying which letters are there
they are able to identify so there is a
we use the visual returns to measure the
visual activity of the rat so the visual
water maze is represented here it's a
pool with two arms and at the end of two
of the two arms there is a computer
screen displaying either the grid gray
stimulus which is a natural stimulus or
energy dark gray team which are all
tournaments of black and white bars
because the rats are very sensitive to
white white and black bars so the rat
has to learn that the platform is
associated with the pattern Stingley so
you can see here and here so we first
place the animals on the platform in
front of the patterns to marry and then
we retract it until the drop and in the
further experiments of the arab
we'll be putting the job releasing the
drop and they will have to swim very fun
very rapidly the swim very rapidly
because they want to escape from the
water and they will have to go on the
hidden platform on to discriminate the
visual pattern so when they do this task
we change the visual the spatial
frequency of the stimulus so it's only
that we increase progressively the
spatial frequency of the stimulus so
when we do that you can see on this
graph the different spatial frequency
and the response of the neurons and you
can see that the animals are performing
very well on these stats we are very
happy they take decision and the
performance is almost one hundred
percent however the more we increase the
spatial frequency of the stimulus at the
moment there are performance reach the
tenth level they are not able to
discriminate the stimulus the patterns
degrees compared to this gray screen so
you can do by yourself the exact piece
on when you delete it be cool oh and see
the different pattern increasing the
special frequency and we will see that
you will not be able to discriminate the
black and white bars after certain
amount of special frequency so the t's
measurement here of the threshold of the
discrimination is the measurement of the
visual acuity and here it's a pond 8.8
psychologically OOP sorry just to let
you know that the when you observe the
Sun animals and the lesion and minerals
do well to the clinic deficit you don't
see any changes between the two groups
that mean that animals that you don't
have a clean attic innovation of v1 I've
are not impaired you should have no the
visual Dixie which which is a good news
for Alzheimer of best patient so they
don't lose their visual acuity when they
lose the cholinergic innovation on 31 so
however if the same anymores are taken
and personal process for a new
discrimination task which is now a
discrimination of orientation so the
animals are to find the platform Eden on
the oblique stimulus the animals are
perform not as well when they have
lesion of the Canaries in cells compared
to the shim sham animals and
specifically near the threshold which
require more attention and more work for
the animals there are not perfect
performing as well so we can conclude
for that that's the projects cells are
not necessary for visual equity or for
perfect vision but they will boost the
new visual neurons in when there is a
learning activity so Oh activation of
new steam line so then if they boost the
cholinergic the if the kinetic cells
fibers boost the yourself does it induce
of so long term enhancements of the
so I will remind you that the long term
announcement is necessary for
acquisition of new visual information
and it's the basis of the memory and
learning even the hippocampus where LTP
process long term for transition process
are making so the question is to see
whether the cholinergic stimulation and
enter long-term potentiation in v1
neurons and we record gave up potential
within the v1 by only inserting an
electronic v1 and measuring the
electrical response to stimulation by a
grating sinusoidal grating and the wave
of potential are the sum of twenty
stimulation difference so the traces of
a neighbor potential look like this one
in black into the control animals in red
or green or euros away it's the the
animals will receive also good energy
simulation so I just want to mention
that the cholinergic stimulation is to
perform only once so we have a baseline
enjoyment of the evoked potential and
then we perform a coupling of the
kinetic stimulation to the visual
stimulation and then we perform only
visual stimulation so the steam
stimulation of the clean energy systems
er by pharmacologically a nudist red cap
a coil which is an analogue of
acetylcholine which is not the great
leader as fast as as as it equally or
the cholinergic system is also activated
by electrical stimulation of the hdb so
both results both by the results in
immense
and of the visual evoked potential
amplitude and the amplitude is a
measured by the difference is we tended
to pick up their input potential so and
you can see that the improvement the
increase of the amplitude of the visual
evoked potential last at least five to
six hour and we did that stop the
experiment after six hour and so it is
sustained in the in the time and it does
not require more cholinergic stimulation
to be effective so the economy
exhibition is made on once very briefly
we wanted to know if these long-term
announcement of the little visual evoked
potential we are done by mechanic
receptor or nicotinic receptor or NMDA
receptor which are involved in long-term
potentiation we did perform the same
experiments by working the mechanic
receptor so you can see here that the
enhancement of the visual evoked
potential is abolished by the Miss Karen
acceptor blockade it's also abolished by
the nicotinic receptor blockade by
making enemy which is non sarà key for
the nicotinic receptor and it is also
abolished by nmda receptor blockade so
all these mechanisms are necessary to
enhance the activity of the neurons in
v1 by the acetylene
so then if when you do one coupling of
the clean energy system with the
neuronal activity visual activity if it
induces long-term effect what does a
utter append when you stimulate many
times will you do many times despairing
as you will do a practice of the sport
or practice of the music instrument so
when you practice your visual capacity
and couple it with the Continental
System what do you see so do you expect
improvement of the visual perception it
will be very great so we did perform a
new test we use the visual water nails
to measure the usual equity and so we do
a first enjoyment of visual equity then
we either implant electrodes in the hdb
in order to stimulate the hdb or do the
lesion of the nerve fibers we perform a
visual training of the animals couple or
not with the visual a cutting-edge
exclamation and then we measure once
again the visual a quickie so we will
compare play and post visual equity and
also we measured the EP the evoked
potential and the perfusion we confuse
the animals to do English to chemistry
to see the nature of the cells involved
so the training a parody is the exposure
on the brick pattern 30 degree patterns
so why do we want to study a an oblique
pattern in fact it is known that the
rats are more sensitive to either
vertical or horizontal patterns and why
because there
living underground so we'll have no too
much different communities so when we
measured the visual acuity for another
dental patterns for example you have
your quite a good visual a quickie 44
back when you do the visual equity for
another pattern the 30 degrees you have
a week visual equity so a week literal
kriti means that you can improve it so
that's why we chose the equity so we did
the exposure of the animal to this
pattern 10 minutes daily during a 8 14
days and we did pair it or not with
electrical stimulation of the hdb so the
effect of the visual training paired
with cholinergic system estimation is
very clear so there is only one group
will improve the visual acuity after the
training it is the group of fat which
were trained with a cholinergic
stimulation on HTTP electrical
stimulation all the other groups the
control animals which were exposed to
grey screen the visual animals which
were not stimulating than for the hdb
all the animals which were stimulated
only for the heb did not show any
improvement of the visual acuity also
the animals which were leavin for the
cholinergic system did not show any
improvement of the visual activity so
that mean that these electrical
stimulation did announce the green
Ezekiel fibers and not other type of
fibers so it's very exciting as a result
and there is something more that we can
videos from to the experiment is that
the announcement of the visual acuity
specific to the pattern the stimuli the
stimulus that we have used for example
you can see that when you perform the
visual activity with 13 degree you
improve the view the visual equity but
if you do the test with an oblique
pattern which is symmetrical to the 30
degree you do not improve the visual
acuity also if you use an oblique
pattern horizontal you would not improve
the visual equity so the enhancement of
the visual capacity is very selective
for the trend in mercy I need important
to know that it doesn't transfer to
other attributes finally does this
effect is correlated to change in the
neurons efficacy in fact yes since only
d HD be coupled to visual stimulation
groups shows an enhancement of the
visual evoked potential and none of the
other boobs or show an enhancement of
the amplitude of behavior evoked
potential so finally we wanted to see
which kind of neurons were involved in
his effect so you can see here that the
double pairing of the visual and kinetic
stimulation induce much blood a lot of
many but the the number of neurons was
increasingly the number of neuron
expressing set forth so which were
activated was intriguing the visual
cortex compared to a visual stimulation
on
the neurons also well staying 41st were
also staying either for gaba so there
was gabaergic sales activity by the
visual stimulation plus drainage
extermination all they were also grita
metallic cells so maybe you don't see
very well but there is a great number of
cells activated by the visual simulation
press the pregnancy stimulation and the
ratio between the excitatory over the
inhibitory cells activated by his
coupled simulation was changing the
different layers of the cortex and from
copying the pairing of the stimulation
compared to the visual or hdb
stimulation alone and you know that the
ratio of the activated cells is involved
in a critical plasticity because the
neurons will each receive an amount of
inhibitory contact or an exit arteries
contact and when these balance is
changing it will change the plasticity
properties of the new ones so it's great
also to know that the cortical
plasticity might be involved in these
coupling so the conclusion of this study
is quite easy so when you do a visual
simulation on me you have a little
improvement of the the activity of the
neurons the processing of the trend
simulation but when you do it in in
consumption or in combination with the
cholinergic stimulation you increase
much more the processing of the train
story
and also the processing of this trans
degree to upper visual areas and I
couldn't give cortical areas so in fact
the coupling will boost the processing
of the this particular steamers and
we'll prioritize it until a conscious
perception in the prefrontal cortex so
the kinetic system is able to enhance
visual performance by modulating v1
which includes change in the v1 response
in amplitude and in quality also change
in the neuron selectivity as some
neurons will have response is a more
efficiently for the oblique pattern or
monuments with a response for this
pattern they will change or adapt their
selectivity the property the mechanism
are very similar to long-term
potentiation and we think that it
induces also seen up to Genesis since
the sequel's is expressed and it's the
first step to expression of different
gene for the synapse plasticity and it
involves Sam's going encoding preceptor
so the coping of the visual stimulation
to the cholinergic stimulation not
training parody could use to improve the
visual perception so this work was done
by a lot of talented student in my lab
as well as a different member of the lab
and it is reported like different
organism financial organism the Canadian
Institutes of Health Research the
Canadian concealer pro research the
vision network from the SL attract us
which is the
formed jajajaja quebec and university of
montreal that's what what and the group
of ferocious entendre video of the
University of not charming so I am open
for your question and thank you very
much for your attention so I don't see
any question I am still on air oops so I
guess that the every